there was one young girl and she was a
victim of rape and she's 13 years old
she couldn't get an abortion that day
and the only way that she could get one
was to travel to New Mexico and her
family did not have that money so you
will now have a 13 year old rape victim
who will be a mother the Legislature
passed a bill that they knew that we
could not comply with and that was the
function of the bill the function is a
trap abortions are completely legal in
this country but many states continue to
pass laws making access to them
increasingly difficult in the past three
years there have been hundreds of
restrictions passed more than in the
past decade and now there's a case
before the Supreme Court that some are
calling the new roe v wade i met with
don porter a filmmaker who spent three
years in the deep south talking to
abortion providers for her documentary
trapped she explained why this case is
so important what we're seeing is
clinics closing at a rapid pace across
America it's been the most dramatic
clinic closing phenomenon in American
history so essentially what you have
today is a right to an abortion but you
don't necessarily have full access to
the places where you could receive an
abortion I remember getting a call once
from a patient she said what if I tell
you what i have in my kitchen cabinet
and you tell me what i could do what
we've actually seen since these laws
have gone into effect is a dramatic
increase in women trying to self abort a
study from the university of texas
estimates that between a hundred
thousand and two hundred and forty
thousand Texas women this is not women
across America but just women in Texas
have tried to self aboard and so what
you see are women hemorrhaging showing
up in the emergency rooms inserting
objects into the vaginal cavity throwing
themselves
stairs harming themselves I mean we're
really in this pre row reality what is
this Supreme Court case that will be
heard and whatever what's at stake so
the laws that are at issue are called
trap flaws they are targeted regulation
of abortion providers the law requires
that doctors who perform abortions have
admitting privileges to a local hospital
and they require that clinics in Texas
become licensed the same way as many
hospitals that sounds like a
common-sense requirement but in practice
most of the hospitals won't give the
credentials so you're in this incredible
catch 22 we've gotten what this country
is about it keeps giving a god up until
now the Supreme Court has spoken and
this is legal so my issue with the trap
laws is that they are underhanded and
sneaky abortion opponents have not been
able to overturn roe v wade so instead
they're kind of going around the
constitution and trying to do it this
way and i think that's bad for our
democracy